Olá pessoal aqui é Dr Alan Dutra prazer
em estar falando com vocês novamente
hoje o assunto é muito importante é a
ansiedade uma das grandes epidemias do
Século XXI nós sabemos que a ansiedade é
um tema muito complexo é um grande
desafio que milhões de pessoas têm que
lidar diariamente quanto alguns
conseguem gerenciar e controlar a
ansiedade de uma maneira mais ou menos
eficaz outras pessoas enfrentam com
grande dificuldade então por isso que
nós vamos falar desse assunto importante
então fique até o final não saia antes
de terminar esse vídeo pro bem de você
da sua família e dos seus amigos Vamos
explorar nesse vídeo como certos
alimentos podem ajudar a controlar e
outros podem ajudar a exacerbar
ansiedade uma mudança na alimentação
pode proporcionar uma mudança muito
radical nos seus sintomas e revolucionar
sua saúde pessoal Todos nós sabemos que
a ansiedade afeta tremendamente a nossa
vida a nossa qualidade de vida é é muito
comum que a gente na nossa mente
transformemos coisas pequenas
preocupações cotidianas em verdadeiros
Monstros gigantescos para muitas pessoas
essa é uma luta silenciosa e que ela não
consegue dividir ou aliviar com seus
amigos mais íntimos isso acontece muitas
vezes porque as pessoas têm medo do
julgamento alheio que as pessoas vão
pensar a respeito desse problema que ela
está vivenciando Então ela prefere ficar
calada ansiedade muito comum que ela
leve a um isolamento social que é muito
prejudicial são muitos sintomas comuns
como palpitações cardíacas suor
excessivo tremores dificuldade de
concentração insônia tensão muscular e
até dificuldades respiratórias e sim
pessoal Existe tratamento a ansiedade
não é uma escolha que você fez é uma
condição que requer toda a atenção
compressão de seus familiares da
sociedade como um modo geral e acima de
tudo é importante você buscar o
tratamento passar uma mensagem de
esperança é muito importante para vocês
porque isso deve ser abordado da melhor
forma possível devemos esclarecer que
tem vários tratamentos naturais eficazes
além de antidepressivos além de
ansiolítico de medicamentos que podem
levar você à dependência psicológica ou
uma dependência física existe opções
naturais e muito menos invasivas
como é o caso de uso de suplementos
ervas terapias diversas técnicas de
liberação emocional exercícios físicos e
alimentação é sobre isso que nós vamos
falar ao longo desse vídeo então não
saia daí continue acompanhando E não se
esqueça de dar o seu like de acenar o
canal e de ativar o Sininho para receber
aviso de novos vídeos existe uma conexão
muito intrínseca entre o intestino e o
cérebro é o chamado eixo intestino
cérebro isso já conhe ido há bastante
tempo na última década e essa conexão
intestino e cérebro pode influenciar
diretamente a nossa ansiedade nosso
estado de humor então nós sabemos que o
intestino tem a segunda maior
concentração de neurônios no nosso
organismo então ele é considerado um
segundo cérebro e que qualquer
desequilíbrio na flora intestinal na
microbiota intestinal seja por maus
hábitos por estresse ou por má
alimentação falta de atividade física F
pode afetar o nosso estado emocional
muitas pesquisas têm mostrado que
pessoas com condições
gastrointestinais as mais variáveis
possíveis como é o caso da s intestino
irritável ou mesmo pessoas constipadas
crônicas Ou que tenha qualquer tipo de
disbiose que é um desequilíbrio entre as
bactérias intestinais as pessoas
frequentemente experimentam altos níveis
de ansiedade e depressão então isso
sugere uma relação muito próxima
intrínseca entre a saúde do nosso
intestino e estado de saúde mental vamos
falar então dos alimentos que pioram a
ansiedade um estudo que foi publicado
recentemente em 2023 mostrou que há um
impacto negativo dos alimentos Fritos
especialmente aqueles ricos em
carboidratos e esse Impacto é ruim na
nossa saúde mental os resultados desse
estudo que envolveu por volta de 140.000
pessoas indicaram que o consumo
frequente de alimentos fritos está
fortemente associada a um risco
aumentado de ansiedade e menor grau da
depressão então é fundamental que nós
evitemos todos os alimentos Fritos que
tenham óleos vegetais que T adição de
gordura trans esses óleos comuns como é
o caso do oro de soja milho canola e
girassol também os alimentos ricos em
carboidratos simples são prejudiciais
com batatas fritas coxinha pastel Então
os alimentos Ultra processados e o
excesso de carboidratos especialmente os
simples não complexos os açúcares em
geral podem provocar altos e baixos no
seu estado de ânimo ao longo do dia
porque causam flutuações drásticas dos
níveis de insulina levando então a
montanha russa metabólica que acaba
afetando o humor e a estabilidade
emocional Então por outro lado tem uns
alimentos benéficos que melhora a nossa
saúde mental entre eles nós temos o
abacate que é rico em magnésio é o
mineral conhecido por equilibrar o
cortisol aumentar os níveis de gaba e
isso vai fazer você ficar mais relaxado
então o abacate também é rico em
vitamina B6 que é essencial pro bom
funcionamento neuronal e a deficiência
pode prejudicar a nossa saúde mental e
os ovos a proteína presente nos ovos
ajuda a manter o açúcar do sangue
estável contribuindo para um estado
emocional mais equilibrado os ovos são
ricos em vários outros nutrientes que
são essenciais paraa saúde mental
incluindo a vitamina D ômega-3 e a
culina que são substâncias muito
importantes pro cérebro e os alimentos
do Mundo Animal eles são ricos em
vitaminas do complexo B que são
essenciais paraa saúde mental
especialmente A3 ab5 ab6 ab9 B12 Então
essas vitaminas em gerais você vai
encontrar através do consumo de
alimentos de origem animal como carnes e
peixes mas também podem estar em feijões
em frutas e legumes então é importante
ter uma alimentação diversificada peixes
e sementes ricas em ômega-3 também são
muito importantes pra saúde cerebral
ômega-3 vai diminuir a inflamação Geral
do organismo inclusive do cérebro e vai
melhorar o desenvolvimento mental então
comer peixes como a sardinha e salmão ou
sementes de chia e de linhaça vão te
ajudar a manter os níveis de ômega-3 ou
ou você pode ainda fazer a suplementação
através do Óleo de peixe ou óleo de
algas outros alimentos muito importantes
são os vegetais folhosos e alguns
legumes então vegetais como a couve O
espinafre o agrião a rúcula E o brócolis
cada um carregando em suas folhas e
caules vários minerais e outros
nutrientes como é o caso do magnésio do
cálcio que são capazes de construir uma
Fortaleza contra a ansiedade então é
muito importante que você gira esses
alimentos para ajudar a controlar esses
sintomas tão desagradáveis a gordura
saudável também é fundamental pra
membrana neuronal pra manutenção dos
neurônios Então temos o azeite o óleo de
coco as nozes amendoas e castanhas todas
elas vão ajudar bastante num caminho
para uma mente mais calma também são
importantes aqueles alimentos são ricos
em fibras que são prebióticas os
prebióticos são os alimentos das baas
térias boas que vivem no nossos
intestinos A microbiota então nós temos
a chia al linhaça aveia psílio
vegetais frutas menos doces e mais ricas
em fibras é o caso da Mora da framboesa
do morango do mirtilo do kiwii e do
Pêssego todos os elementos esses
vegetais são muito importantes através
das suas fibras prebióticas que vão
alimentar as bactérias boas no intestino
e vão ajudar a recuperar esse órgão tão
Nobre Deixando as suas bactérias boas e
amigas muito felizes outros alimentos
importantes são os
fermentados você pode fazer alimentos
fermentados vegetais na sua casa e
consumir todo dia uma pequena porção
exemplo Chucrute quinx picles
fermentados os fermentados eles atuam
como probióticos e também prebiótico
então eles vão fornecer as fibras e
também bactérias boas e outro micro
organismos interessantes que vão ajudar
na sua saúde intestinal e por
consequência naa saúde cerebral caldo de
ossos outro superalimento ele é rico em
nutrientes como minerais como colágeno
vai ajudar a restaurar a parede
intestinal reparar a saúde do nosso
intestino que é super importante paraa
conexão cérebro intestino melhorando a
tua ansiedade então fechando a barreira
intestinal que está super hiper
permeável
você vai ajudar a que seu cérebro
Recupere a sua calma a sua tranquilidade
Então pessoal fique muito atentos a sua
alimentação fiquem muito atentos ao seu
estado de humor procurem meditar isso é
muito importante procure dar grande
valor as suas horas de sono então faça
uma meditação diária antes de dormir nem
que seja de um a 5 minutos junto com uma
oração isso vai ajudar muito a controlar
a sua ansiedade e também vai ajudar
a manter o seu cérebro saudável não se
esqueça de assistir esses vídeos tão
importantes pra sua saúde divulgar o
canal para seus amigos e familiares
coloque o link desse vídeo na sua rede
social ajude outras pessoas a ter saúde
como você pessoal Muito obrigado pela
sua atenção você é fera um beijo no seu
coração